al cumplir 100 días en el poder Lula
recorre el estado de marañao allí unas
53 ciudades se declararon en emergencia
por las lluvias e inundaciones que
afectaron a unas 36.000 familias el
presidente acompañado por varios de sus
ministros llamó a la unión de los
diferentes sistemas de gobierno
creo que tenemos que cuidar a las
personas que fueron víctimas la gente
pide colchones la gente pide cilindros
la gente pide cualquier cosa que le
pueda dar cierta comodidad lo que el
gobierno puede hacer
este cruce entre el Gobierno Federal el
gobierno Estatal y gobiernos municipales
es obligatorio obligatoria el mandatario
brasileño ha hecho de los programas
sociales el centro de la agenda de sus
primeras 14 semanas en el poder al
restaurar subsidios y ayudas para
reducir la pobreza que habían sido
derogados por su antecesor Yahir
bolsonaro la inclusión en su gobierno de
minorías sexuales raciales y étnicas
también estableció un cambio en el trato
a estos grupos y la mujer con respecto a
la administración anterior la gestión
del partido de los trabajadores ha
marcado un punto de giro además en la
protección del medio ambiente con
Especial cuidado en el tema de la
deforestación en la amazonía brasilera
la política exterior de Lula también le
ha otorgado ritmo a su mandato el
regreso a la celac el reintegro a la
unasur la reactivación de relaciones con
Venezuela y los esfuerzos por la paz en
Ucrania han puesto a Brasil nuevamente
en el escenario internacional
en estos primeros meses de gobierno Lula
enfrentó un desafío sin precedentes en
la vida democrática de la nación el
asalto a la sede de los tres poderes en
Brasilia por parte de Los Seguidores del
expresidente bolsonaro lo que le dejó
además el reto de disminuir la
polarización